now let's get some more on the r number
down from 1.2
to 1.3 uh last week to 0.821 we can
speak to our science correspondent
thomas moore for
more on this um thomas on the face of it
this looks like really good news just an
estimate but it does seem as though
the lockdown is having a good outcome
certainly it's beginning to turn the
corner on cases nationally
but it doesn't uh seem to be the case
in all regions and that will be a
concern and very
broadly the reduction in the r number
is consistent with the case numbers that
we had from the office for national
statistics
infection surveys weekly survey
a couple of hours back which also showed
a downturn
in cases but it is going to be a problem
in in the northeast and
some areas at the southwest too where
both the r
number and uh the number of infections
still seems to be increasing and that
will be
a concern uh that lockdown has yet to
have
an effect and that may partly be because
those regions were not in tier four
as was the case the southeastern and
london uh where cases had already begun
to level off
before lockdown and that uh trend has
continued
uh in their other regions they were in
in lower tiers people were able to mix
over christmas and we may still be
seeing
an effect of that of course it is also
the case that the new variant of the
virus is taking longer
to ripple away from the southeast of
england which is where it took hold
first and it's taking longer for it to
affect
other regions but it's not good news for
hospitals in those regions
because they will inevitably see an
increasing admissions
in the next fortnight or so okay thomas
thank you